en un simbólico ritual indígena luízar
se recibió el bastón de mando que
representa el liderazgo que asumirá como
presidente de bolivia este 8 de
noviembre ar se tomará juramento tras
lograr una aplastante victoria en las
pasadas elecciones del 18 de octubre
recibimos en tiawanaku la energía de la
pachamama y los ancestros para gobernar
en paz unidad y prosperidad no
defraudaremos la confianza del pueblo al
dejar el cargo de presidente de bolivia
ar se relevará allá nine años quien
asumió el poder de forma interina en
2019 tras unas fallidas elecciones
presidenciales que provocaron la salida
del ex presidente evo morales y sumieron
al país en una crisis política a su
ceremonia asistirán los presidentes de
argentina alberto fernández de colombia
iván duque y de paraguay mario abdo
benítez así como el rey felipe sexto de
españa y una serie de delegaciones de
los países vecinos la instalación de
arce en el gobierno fue la oportunidad
para que evo morales regresará al país
tras haber estado exiliado en argentina
el ex mandatario tiene previsto llegar a
bolivia por vía terrestre este lunes en
medio de una caravana en la que récord
a varias ciudades no está claro si
morales planea reintegrarse a la vida
pública sin embargo su heredero luís
arce dejó claro que no habrá un papel
para él en este gobierno